salut les épicuruses et les epicurieux
vous aussi vous êtes accro à votre
smartphone connaissez-vous l'histoire du
plus célèbre d'entre eux l'iPhone
savez-vous qu'au départ personne ne
croyait en son succès et pourtant il a
sauvé de la faillite la société qui l'a
créé la fameuse marque à la pomme
aujourd'hui les hauts de la chaîne
techmaker nous racontent cette fabuleuse
épopée
allô Léo nous sommes pendus à tes lèvres
j'ai ami tu vas voir cette histoire est
complètement dingue
nous sommes le 9 janvier 2007 au moscown
Center de San Francisco Steve Jobs le
patron emblématique de la société Apple
s'apprête à faire une annonce
fracassante dans le cadre d'une nouvelle
quinote pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas
une kinote c'est une conférence
événement organisée par la marque à la
pomme leur but est de présenter de tout
nouveau produit aujourd'hui job the va
dévoiler un téléphone qui devrait selon
lui bouleverser le monde de la
téléphonie son nom l'iPhone seul sur
scène il dévoile pour la première fois
son mystérieux téléphone en prononçant
ses mots un super bypot tactile un
téléphone portable et un formidable
appareil permettant d'aller sur internet
ce ne sont pas trois appareils mais un
seul aujourd'hui Apple va réinventer le
téléphone en réunissant trois produits
en un cet appareil se veut tout
simplement révolutionnaire pour Jobs
l'enjeu est taille l'iPhone a pour
mission de relancer définitivement Apple
qui a frôlé la faillite il y a quelques
années mais contre toute attente les
journalistes et les spécialistes
présents dans la salle se montrent
dubitatif
permettront d'Apple leur promettait une
révolution mais bien c'est raté son
iPhone n'aurait rien d'innovant ouais
les premiers téléphones que l'on peut
qualifier d'intelligence date des années
90 et à l'époque ils ont fait un énorme
flop c'est le cas du Symon commercialisé
par IBM en 1994 il s'agit du premier
téléphone mobile à écran tactile de
l'histoire ils dispose d'un service de
messagerie peut envoyer et recevoir des
fax et il est aussi équipé d'un
traitement de texte mais cet appareil
n'a jamais trouvé son public d'une part
les gens n'en comprennent pas l'utilité
d'autre part il est beaucoup trop cher
400 euros contre 80 euros pour un
portable classique de l'époque en
découvrant l'iPhone les concurrents
d'Apple ne se privent pas de critiquer
ce smartphone n'a aucune chance de
s'imposer auprès du grand public aucune
affirme ton chez Microsoft c’est aussi
la vie de peu de macherie Warriors la
directrice des nouvelles technologies
chez Motorola à l'époque cette
entreprise est l'un des mastodontes de
la téléponie mobile selon elle l'iPhone
n'a rien de révolutionnaire l'interface
tactile capteur de mouvement
accéléromètre reconnaissance de gestes
caméras de mégapixels lecteur MP3
intégré WiFi Bluetooth bref rien de neuf
sous le soleil la première vue on
pourrait penser que les concurrents de
la marque à la pomme font preuve d'une
évidence mauvaise foi l'iPhone leur fait
il peur craint-il d’être dépassé rien de
tout cela en vérité leur réaction est
parfaitement compréhensible comment le
patron d'Apple peut-il espérer capter
des parts de marché avec des
technologies déjà disponibles sur les
produits vendus par les leaders de
l'industrie comme Motorola Nokia et
Samsung sans parler du prix 399 euros
c'est beaucoup trop cher et ce n'est pas
tout à cette époque l'affirme américaine
doit faire face à d'autres obstacles et
pas des moindres en 2007 les contrats
téléphoniques ne sont pas accessibles
comme ils le sont aujourd’hui rien qu'en
France les prix des forfaits sont
démesurés ils ne comprennent pas
d’abonnement internet et on prime le
nombre de SMS et les temps d'appels sont
limités
pour profiter de ce fameux iPhone on est
contraint de l'acheter avec un forfait
Orange doublé d'un engagement
obligatoire d'au moins deux ans et enfin
cerise sur le gâteau l'appareil ne
propose pas de boutiques numériques
permettant de télécharger de nouvelles
applications il faut se contenter de
celles qui sont fournies avec le
téléphone donc les mails le calendrier
bref rien de très folichon alors bien
sûr il y a quand même cet appareil photo
intégrer et c'est un bon point mais que
vaut-il vraiment en réalité ces
caractéristiques techniques sont très
limitées il comporte un capteur photo de
deux mégapixels autant dire que l'on est
loin très loin des 48 mégapixels
présentés sur le dernier modèle de la
marque mais il en faudrait plus pour
entamer le moral de Steve Jobs son
iPhone il y croit dur comme faire il
faut dire que le patron d'Apple est ce
qu'on appelle un dur à cuire c'est un
personnage à part dans la galaxie des
grands patrons du numérique ce n'est pas
un technicien ce n'est pas un geek non
plus Jobs est un visionnaire un rêveur
qui fonctionne à l'intuition certains
d'entre vous se souviennent peut-être
que six ans plus tôt en 2001 il avait
pris tout de cours avec l'iPod un petit
baladeur numérique sorti tout droit de
son imagination en quelques mois cet
appareil a complètement changé notre
manière de consommer la musique pour en
faire la promotion Jobs avait même
trouvé une utilité la toute petite poche
de notre jeans celle qui ne sait rien
pénétrer il fourrait son iPod grâce à ce
petit bijou de technologie le PDG
d'Apple a réussi à relancer la société
qui était au bord du dépôt de bilan une
sacrée revanche pour celui qui avait été
viré par la firme 16 ans plus tôt en
1985 grave erreur d'après son départ la
société connaît une véritable descente
aux enfers elle ne parvient plus à être
innovante ces produits sont trop chers
elle propose trop de modèles les
consommateurs n'y comprennent plus rien
et ils finissent par se tourner vers les
PC meilleur marché et plus simple
d'utilisation face à snaufrage Apple
avait finalement réintégré job en 1997
depuis rien ne semble l'arrêter et en ce
mois de janvier 2007 il en est persuadé
on est à l'aube d'une révolution son
smartphone pourrait bien faire d'Apple
le nouveau leader mondial de
il faut attendre le 29 juin 2007 jour de
sa mise en vente pour savoir si
l'intuition de Jobs était la bonne et
comme il le pressentait son téléphone
connaît immédiatement un succès
phénoménal qui fait mentir tous les
pronostics le réveil est difficile pour
les concurrents d'Apple ils n'ont pas
compris que l'iPhone est un produit
novateur très éloigné des standards de
l'époque ni les centré sur l'utilisateur
avec un design pensé pour lui simplifier
la vie pour la première fois c'est le
téléphone qui s'adapte à l'utilisateur
et non l'inverse un enfant de 4 ans peut
comprendre en deux secondes comment on
s'en sert pas besoin de mode d'emploi
c'est le secret de son succès la
simplicité n'était pas un critère
prioritaire pour les autres marques leur
interface sont plus austères les unes
que les autres les écrans sont aussi
bien plus petits la faute un clavier
complet en dessous de leur écran et une
molette pour naviguer entre les
applications c'est le cas par exemple du
Blackberry dans un univers où les outils
sont peu pratiqués trop complexes
l'arrivée d'un appareil ludique et
attrayant bah c'est du pain béni pour
les consommateurs forts de ce succès
veulent ne perd pas de temps pour
améliorer son téléphone et à peine un an
plus tard le 9 juin 2008 l'iPhone 3G
déboule sur le marché et cette fois bah
il met tout le monde d'accord cette
nouvelle version est plus aboutie elle
comporte enfin cette fameuse boutique
d'applications qui lui manquait tant et
ça bah c'est l'App Store qui est
toujours en service aujourd'hui en prime
ce nouveau modèle profite de l'évolution
de la législation en France par exemple
le Conseil de la concurrence suspend
l’exclusivité d'orange ce qui permet à
tout le monde de s'offrir un iPhone quel
que soit l'opérateur que l'on a choisi
dès lors l'iPhone devient le produit
incontournable il n'est plus la chasse
gardée des iris adopters c'est le nom
que l'on donne aux aficionsados des
nouvelles technologies cet appareil
devient immensément populaire en
quelques mois à peine et surtout le mot
smartphone lui est désormais associé
donc qui est à Motorola et tous les
concurrents d'Apple sont au tapis
pendant que l'iPhone inonde le marché il
sauve si nappe proposer de vieux
téléphones classiques qui sont désormais
perçus par le public comme des
antiquités certains ne sont relèveront
pas c'est le cas de BlackBerry qui
cherche à
donc l'affirmer aujourd'hui l'iPhone a
non seulement sauvé Apple mais il en a
fait le leader mondial sur le marché du
smartphone aujourd’hui le géant
américain n’est plus tout à fait
précurseur en matière de nouvelles
fonctionnalités la reconnaissance
faciale ou le point son caméra ont été
inventés par d'autres mais Apple reste
la marque qui a popularisé le smartphone
ce qui veut dire beaucoup pour pas mal
de gens là où il se trouve Steve Jobs
doit se frotter les mains merci Léo
c'était passionnant j'ignorais tous les
détails de cette histoire et une fois de
plus je suis complètement scotché par le
côté visionnaire de Steve Jobs et si
vous avez aimé cette vidéo n'hésitez pas
à mettre un pouce bleu ou à vous abonner
si ce n'est pas encore fait et surtout
dites-moi en commentaire quel sujet tech
vous aimeriez que l'on traite allez à
très bientôt les épicurios et les
épicurieux
[Musique]